you are a giant female anaconda in
Venezuela you're 13 feet long and you
are hungry no make that you are starving
and you've got your little asides on the
largest rodents on the planet
capybaras adults can grow more than four
feet long and can top 100 pounds you be
anaconda can't really see your prey all
that well but your tongue pulls in scent
molecules that tell you this is the
massive meal you want to swallow in one
prolonged gulp both you and the cat
laverra's spend most of your time in the
water and one unfortunate capybara will
have nowhere to hide when you hunt it at
high speed you slither under water
popping your head out to make sure your
aim is true the big reason you're so
focused on a satisfying meal is that
you're about to mate and only well-fed
snakes breathe successfully once you get
pregnant you won't eat again until your
babies are born 7 months later so you'd
better stuff yourself to the scales now
these birds can save themselves but the
capivara
it's a goner anacondas don't poison
their prey they ambush them they bite
then coil around and crush the surprised
creature to death your death grip is so
fierce the victim not only can't breathe
its blood can't circulate you've
suffered for this meal the capybara took
a bite out of you but you get the last
laugh when your elastic jaws begin
swallowing your enormous victim head
first your last meal before mating has
taken six hours to ingest not digest
just get it into your gut
the digestion takes several days after
that you'll be fit and full ready for
that successful breeding